I'm not mad about Pearl Harbor what yeah
now I'll never eat sushi they're still
the enemy I'm still an active army no my
grandfather I swear to God my
grandfather fought in World War two and
he wouldn't eat sushi to the day he died
he would say that he wouldn't you
wouldn't eat it
I'm tired of that just when Americans go
it was a sneak attack they were angry
about it
right but that's war yeah it is Emperor
Hirohito supposed to call Roosevelt and
go yeah head oh no it's me you know
how's the family here either way I'm
gonna take it tomorrow morning you know
that's a good point yeah really good
point its strategic yeah no this they're
sleeping in Pearl Harbor and they don't
know we're coming
yeah now listen babe it was a attack but
it's like I get I get one that had to do
what they had to do I get why the
Japanese had to do what they had to do
we we're now treating them fairly
treating them like second-class citizens
since World War one and then they came
in then we stopped [ __ ] paying for
their oil we stopped the oil we said
we're not giving you any more oil to
take over [ __ ] to China so they said
listen babe the only way oh you're the
Pacific feet out of the ocean it didn't
work yeah and then the whole country got
put in a microwave what's gonna happen
you know and but I'm not but what I'm
saying is mess with the boys the
Japanese yes with the boys you woke up
the boys yeah it's a situation it's
unfortunate that that happened but I do
not blame the Japanese for doing what
they did and I also you know war is
disgusting it's ugly and it sucks but
it's not going anywhere but I you know
but do you think just it is a probably
open for debate but do you think that
nuclear bombs was a little too much I
think I think the second one was a lot
the second one and the first one is
debatable I don't I wouldn't have chose
to use it but but the other I think
about the other options from the from
the allies point of view they said we're
gonna lose a million soldiers if we
invade Tokyo so or we can just drop some
nuclear juice on these people and see
what happens yeah and I don't I don't
think it was right I don't think it was
right what the United States did I do
not don't call it juice but no they kept
saying well listen you know Truman
Truman kept saying he kept saying Japan
he said just give up your countries
give up and the Japanese pride said
we're not going to do it we're not gonna
do we're not gonna do it so he said
you've given us no choice either you
give up by today and we're not and or
you're gonna be a bento box and that's
what happened
you know what I mean and I and I know
that everyone's gonna be a little
traumatized yeah I don't know and I'm
saying it's wrong yeah I know it's wrong
but it's like you know it's war you got
to give up George Washington am i
fascinate with George Washington one of
the best books ever at 1776 about the
start of our country they said the best
thing about George Washington is what
his number-one quality was is he was
able to see things as they were not as
he wishes they were so he was very good
at withdrawing and he would say when
other generals would say no we have to
attack them for the pride of our country
saying you know we're gonna get [ __ ]
smacked by these Redcoat cuties if we
take one more step further so you'd say
we will withdraw and then he constantly
did that and played that game and then
we won our independence where the
Japanese were saying I want to I want to
see things as I wish there are I think
we can beat them it's like babe babe you
can't with the United States of America
we got the boys and we're charged up
because you did a sneak attack you
sneaky Fox well the problem also is is
that they idolized Emperor Hirohito as a
Sun God sure Raja and so when the people
it's like Hitler right when people
swallow that pill huh and many times you
know you guys know I'm a trump supporter
right so don't worry you're gonna get
away you're gonna get away with it you
got the right look but if you're
speaking our language right now yeah I
think he's just making good choice
that's a good choice and the [ __ ]
cucked out Hollywood wants to say
[Music]
that was the buds that can't cosine now
yeah yeah it's just cuz your brother
your brother worked for the Obama mr.
Boddy read a little Wikipedia before I
got oh I get a tater I know him